good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone back welcome back to GameSpot's
best of 2017 countdown we have already
announced our top six games no six of
our top ten games so now we are on
number four we are about to get to that
just reiterate tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. we
will be announcing three two and one and
then before that you can go catch up on
all the games we've announced so far but
first without further ado let's show off
our number four best of 2017 game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your bar to cease our wonderful we need
to go we need to come now
it's time for something to eat
[Music]
almost
are you having fun yet
[Applause]
stay
[Music]
[Laughter]
rather than evil seven biohazard by
Capcom game that released almost a year
ago at this point is GameSpot's
collective number four game of 2017 I'm
Mike McCarty and brought on Peter Brown
again hello friends
Matty Spinelli hello and Joey hi Joey
you made that you just made that montage
video and I figured I'd bring you to him
because you both like this game a lot
it was my number two game of the year
personally so I'm I guess I'm better
than you guys no I'm just kidding it's a
it's just from joking this game is a
fantastic on many levels Matt what is it
about this game that kind of like
reinvigorated your love for Resident
Evil well I get it
obviously the most apparent thing about
it that made really instantly pulled me
in obviously was the very like how it
returned back to sort of the horror
roots in the series and not only that I
mean it because it brings in a lot of
great you know like all that sort of
tense like horrifying like it you know
atmosphere that the the earlier games
had but but it also the same time felt
very much like an old-school Resident
Evil game yeah same time even just some
of the new ideas sprinkled in there but
like was it like in the earlier part of
the game like what really kind of like
pulled me in its thing it was like wait
a minute
I am I'm in order to unlock a door I'm
gathering three like service keys and
stuff this is like again in a long time
so it might be like the like the helmet
shield sword keys from Rezo on yeah and
kind of touched on it but Joey this is
much more of a survival game than like
resonable 6 was the last numbered entry
in the series obviously if you played
the Revelations game those kind of had
horror elements but this game is
actually pretty scary in my opinion yeah
did you find that as well yeah okay well
for from my perspective I feel like I
have a unique view on it just because I
played the entire thing in VR which
changed I feel like a lot of it a lot of
the game to me from one I guess the
aiming was a little bit easier but also
just being able to like look around the
environments it makes the environments
feel just a lot more scary and it makes
a scares also feel more earned I feel
and just plain and like that is the it
just makes me so much more tense where
you
like look behind certain objects without
like being spotted or just like looking
back from you know when Jax chasing you
can look behind you he's like still
running after you you can have that more
sensible awareness and in a in a way
that makes it a lot more terrifying it's
one less like layer of removal right
like you can just say oh this is
happening to somebody else you're just
right in the middle of it but Matt like
as someone who has played the older
games did you feel like this game was
good in the sense of the survival
aspects like actually inventory
management and managing your actual
supplies because obviously you can craft
chem fluids with gunpowder to make
handgun bullets but you can also do chem
fluid with with other supplies to make
like you know psychostimulants or like
ammo for specific weapons you have to
kind of have that risk reward mentality
do you think that that survival paid off
in this game in terms of the design
totally I always like throughout the
entirety of the game I always felt like
you know like I was on the cusp of like
okay maybe I might not have enough
enough ammo to take on this situation
but a lot of the mechanics that it does
put in there that you know that sort of
forces you to sort of make decisions to
be like okay should I use this gunpowder
to craft a motion I use this this herb
to craft a like in like a first aid can
and stuff which is like in a way like as
a fancy like you kind of makes you
reminds you of like present evil 3 if
like the whole like crafting of like
ammo and stuff but yeah like all that
stuff that was in the in the game in
terms of that like really it felt great
and it always kept you on edge and
that's what I loved about it and like
and just like the the sheer amount like
that was something I wasn't really
expecting at the same time too when I
played this game was that like you know
sure like oh this is gonna be like going
back to horror but like it really did
bring back that sort of survival aspect
to it
also just as much yeah well you have to
be thinking at all times like okay try
to keep this item in my inventory like
should I kind of offload some stuff okay
I'm gonna go on another run let me see
what kind of supplies I could pick up
yeah Joey you said something interesting
before we went alive you were saying it
kind of the as rebel 7 kind of pans out
we won't spoil anything later in the
game is there are some great surprises
that despite the fact the game came out
a year ago I still think people are
better off experiencing on their own but
you were saying it's almost like
resonable 7 if you play through it you
get the sense that you're also kind of
playing through the history of
Resident Evil the series itself right in
the sense that the game starts off
really really slow like you hope you
wake up like you know in a house in like
I'm new you explore the mansion the
first thing you do and like as you go on
through the game you slowly acquire more
weapons you encounter more like
dangerous enemies not just Jack Baker
but also like the rest of this family
and as you progress throughout the game
you you yeah but yeah then like it's
also like amazing to me how fluidly the
game like transitions from like you said
like this this Texas Chainsaw Massacre
inspired kind of house in the bayou like
down in the south like kind of deep bog
area but then it goes to like this more
there's a character who's sadistic and
set up booby traps for you throughout
the section and then it's also kind of
more like saw like psychological horror
someone's toying with you and you're
trying to figure out how to deal with
that while also take them down but also
play their games at the same time and
then again later on it goes more to
Resident Evil kind of like it harkens
back to the bioterrorism aspects it's
it's so like fluid in the way it
transitions between them and I feel like
it earns it despite the fact that
they're all such different horror
influence it's it feels like it's all of
a piece in this game I'm at did you find
the same thing or did you think that it
stumbled in any of those aspects no I
didn't if anything I did find it really
like that was the craziest thing about
it was like it was that was so
surprising about is that I was able to
just really change like toe a change
like the kinds of things you were doing
like that's all chapter I did not expect
them to go for that kind of thing yeah
but just the game really handled itself
very well very gracefully in that regard
of just how it was you know an
embodiment of Prima not just like
bringing it back to you like old
resident evil but just like well the
entire series as a whole like just
because like obviously you have the more
slow sort of foreboding elements of the
horror of the Horde that you see in like
the older games ball also having someone
like the more action the elements that
appeared in the later games especially
like for example like the precision
aiming and stuff like that just felt
like resin go for and just even like yet
the end even had very sort of
action-packed moments that we're we're
like 5 yes it in some regards
yeah it's so like I think the common
refrain when we first saw this was that
oh there go
for us silent hill's vibe and I think
it's just being reductive obviously
because it's first-person there nothing
like each other from what we see himself
knows who knows what silent hill's would
have been if like kojima did get the
green light to do it but if you want to
get into semantics of course like Capcom
was saying like yeah we've been we had
this idea in development before silent
hill's a thing like first person horror
like you know the indie scene kind of
kicked off with amnesia the Dark Descent
or I mean like I'm so um I had it like
last year's outlast yeah I mean despite
like whoever did it first it feels like
resin Evil seven really almost like
reinvigorated triple-a horror for me
earlier this year when it kind of like
sprung out to the scene but Joey you
were saying like you played through the
whole thing in VR I feel like horror was
one of the drawing points of VR for me
for a long time or at least the idea of
good horror in VR but for resi no seven
to come along and actually show it could
be done I mean like what's the last time
you played a full-length game in VR and
just like said that was the best way to
play it if you had an alternative I've
never done that actually yeah like does
this like was this game just outside of
survival horror and outside of as evil
did this game also kind of give you more
impetus to try out VR in general hmm I'm
not I'm not sure if it would like
encourage me to play more like I tend to
actually get motion sick pretty easily
which was surprising for this game
that's the biggest compliment that I can
give it is that it didn't make me sick
and I was able to play it for like three
or four hours at a time yeah in general
especially in VR is unreal like there's
the part in the Attic of the old house
where you're walking around the corner
then you hear the piano quickly go yeah
like tinkle tinkle tinkle tinkle but
then like you hear it but in VR is way
scarier then you go in and no one's in
the room of the piano but or you can't
peek around the corner yeah but I mean
like in general Matt looking back again
this game came out January 23rd I
believe 2017 I could be a few days off
it's somewhat yeah and like looking back
on it what was the one thing that stuck
with you and made it like made you say
yeah we need this in our top 5 because a
bunch people GameSpot agree with you but
I remember you were blending people
arguing for it was the one thing that
really stuck with me
um yeah like just the legacy of the
series and we were like just in general
how it like brought resin evil 7 back
into the limelight you were mentioning
before we went live
I mean that there's so much damn the one
thing that kind of stuck with me that it
really is just the idea of it being just
not like it being it just it
accomplishing so much all at yes it
being just a classic like going like
going back to those old Resident Evil
games iterating on stuff from the from
then like the later ones and then
providing its own new ideas while also
just like like it like it's a soft
reboot and that's the thing that's most
crazy about it too is that like you know
it could be seen as like a totally new
game and you can jump into but at the
same time if you're like an old-school
fan you can just go put you can just put
this right into the timeline yeah this
cheesy melodramatic timeline that is
Resident Evil and you could still like
enjoy and be like wow yeah this I guess
that's the craziest thing about it to
you is just that it really it has that
sort of expanded universe approach to
and I think that that's something that
those really cool but with Capcom yet
here is that like ya know this is still
in that universe but you know what it's
gonna be a different tone yeah and it's
still gonna we're still gonna use those
characters still gonna have all these
elements in there but it's gonna stand
on its own while still being a part of
this dagger thing yeah by all accounts
resonable seven biohazard is a
spectacular marriage of res evils past
and future and rightfully deserving of
our numbers for spot on the list our
collective opinion at GameSpot again if
you're watching is live we are going to
be talking about our numbers three
through one games the only games we
thought collectively we're better than
res evil 7:00 tomorrow 10:00 a.m.
Pacific which is Wednesday December 20th
but in the meantime go catch up with all
our other game of the Year content the
other six games we've mentioned I guess
I can rattle through them quick Nier
automata I was number 10 what remains of
youth Finch was number nine you go hell
blade setting with sacrifices eight yeah
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus seven
horizon zero down six divinity original
sin to was five reliable service for
number four game if you're watching this
on youtube reviews by that fact go to
catch up on everything else we've talked
about right now if you're watching this
live we're gonna be streaming the game
mild spoiler warning if you're watching
this if you don't want anything spoiled
and rosie was seven at all it's been out
a year but i still would like people to
experience there are all these stuff for
the first time maybe if they haven't
tried it but if you want to watch
we are pretty early in the game
like two hours we have Matt start
playing right now we got this hooked up
I saved from Joey your campaign yeah
is this the campaign did you play to you
up to this point VR now yeah I play
through the whole thing in VR like this
beginning okay cool so we need you have
the last dog head right yeah sweet where
do I do it right on back
it's weird so it yeah so you're finally
this is the first time you leave the
mansion well unless you count the very
beginning of the game you're not in the
mansion but first I'm out in the yard
yeah yeah
so you're gonna run it's probably some
molded maybe not yet different kind of
remake this is kind of the equivalent of
going to the backyard
yeah to the the guards quarters is a
guards quarters the grounds keepers
quarters exactly yes sir the [ __ ] yes
should got that Wolfen coin hoc
medallions what a big coin on the table
yeah the tricky cheese token this is
cool and I realized that you collecting
like you you get like if you're paying
attention you can get seven or eight
antique coins up to this point yeah and
you don't know what they're for is like
oh these are junk and then you realize
holy [ __ ] moving by day trades yeah
which one did you buy oh oh hey belies
would be pretty good we just took
steroids yeah we Joey just didn't use
the steroids he found above the
fireplace yeah in the rec room you
Michael no the rec rooms upstairs the
fireplace is kind of like little grab
this room oh sorry
the Romans did oh man those people are
gonna be mad at you you can use that as
actual health like what yeah if you were
unread you could use it on it you're
fine you still got the increase but I'm
mad at you you can use it as well
I was not alright well put in your what
women on VHS I know Joey collects the
rock on the VHS go check the toilet
quick toilet yeah find that something in
there yeah yes Magnum Oh super cool Mike
Mahoney do
I'm not kidding maybe you have to find a
treasure photo first they put Magnum
bullets in there later oh yeah no I come
back after Zoey calls you in your after
uh again mild spoiler warning after
Lucas puts the cops head in the fridge
and gives you the clue right that's when
he starts toying with leftovers this is
Zoey I was thinking about this earlier
when when you were talking about the
game but like I think one of the things
I forgot about was how each pretty much
each character or each each member of
the Baker family represents like a
different play style in the game yeah
which I like I just thought about that
like right now is like whoa yes like
because Jack kind of plays like the
Nemesis style like chasing you throw
like the whole mansion Marguerite's kind
of like the I would say Marguerite's
like akin to I mean you you're using
stealth to get around her at first but
her boss fight is like at one of the
better resonable seven or as evil boss
fights in general it's like a resonable
for boss fight where they give you a
sandbox to run around and gather
supplies and kind of use it to your
advantage although she used it to her
advantage as well coming through the
ceiling and windows and stuff it was
terrifying
first half through yeah jewel techs are
really good in the green house actually
did it here in the office I remember I
was like oh yeah all right man let's get
to the old house be all that yeah we um
check the turlet again wait yeah drop
the uh you could pop those in the
backyard that's actually worth or I can
just show you where this stuff is get
the germs business oh yeah man oh okay
actually keep the broken handgun okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you a little
tip go you might have done this already
so go toward the back deck of the house
okay I believe it's either on the left
side of stairs or no no go down like I
don't check the latticework under the
deck there's a panel you can pry off it
might be on the left side of stairs is a
memory there being yeah it's on the left
side is there's there's also a shadow
puzzle back here with the hatchet but do
you right look we're here yeah that
metal panel to your right
what right there I'll peel that off oh
and there's a repair kit in there so you
can repair that broken handgun to get a
better tennis see there's one other
repair kit in the game I believe it's in
the Lucas's section a treasured photo
and then you can use that to repair
you broke a track on which you first use
to get the main shot there the first
second so you can use that right now if
you want oh yeah yeah there you go you
just thought ten bullets in the original
handgun I don't think you can just
transfer those in any way you might just
want to use those ten first it was just
like a different weapon or different mo
all together they're not that it's not
different animal it still you can't like
unless if you switch to advanced now you
just saw something in the birdbath back
there oh yeah yeah but I tell ya there's
a bunch of the Dan T chord you're stuck
more tokens I know some herbs around
yeah should we speak I don't know what
that means
oh there's a lockpick behind you on the
stairs in that flowerpot on the web side
of the stairs that's too much stuff in
this game okay but I gonna candle off
it's a baws Oh No enough stuff and then
there's a chem fluid under the trailer I
believe oh my god hey you'll come back
here you don't need yeah yeah that's
true
let's go fight just gonna go fight
something since this is part of the game
they like inventory management yeah
tough to just run straight to the next
section without can you I would bring
burner fuel I guess you don't need those
yeah psycho stems
I'll be your psychostimulant well okay
yeah
was that Mach arena yeah yeah Scott
saying back
how perfectly that fits within the
Macarena Marguerite are now saying like
Nick Nick's name in it
she's he's watching plaintiff that seed
ok later on when you do that saw section
a lot of these boxes are booby trap
plays with your expectation I know yeah
what you've come to do throughout the
entire games then you start like
deciding whether or not to knife them
but they'll explode if you hit the wrong
one so then I was talking to someone who
told me or I guess like the net bullet
gained from the boxes is good enough
that you are better off shooting the
boxes with your handgun yeah just to
save health unless you really know the
game and know which ones the knife and
which ones is it random do you know I
don't know I think it's just like
logically on your first playthrough
you're better off shooting them but I
might I don't think any of this game is
procedurally generated well yeah I guess
so like the mold it don't always come
out at the same time yeah so you know
get that burner jeez
oh you did differently usually replaying
this with a merry kiss recently and she
went straight for the first door and
then Marguerite scared them the Jews
aside oh I got backpack inventory
upgrade here - yeah yeah I think it's
funny playing through this second time
and seeing the difference it like like
the gate Oh obviously the whole game
changes based on the copies your
intimate knowledge no before everything
is but variant developed oddly different
playing through at this time I got
intimate with this game mm-hmm yeah
Kendall there's a bobble head in here
yeah
sweet trap should be save and actually
do that everybody's gonna know
auto-saving okay for sure at certain
points if you play a madhouse you get I
think you shall move played through
though most of the game it's not the
whole thing on that house and the
unlimited saves no you have to you can't
there's no auto-saving you have to
actually I think you have a limited
number of saves with the recorders oh
wait no it's like dogs true very this a
lot more pesky during the boss fight she
sends these out to annoy you but right
before she descends on you
you'll heal puck so I heard stuff
you could knife those off if you're
patient enough but you can keep hopping
on you though
no you can get it during certain
distance where they don't but it's
better to just get yeah there's also
lying like that door is locked or that
drawer back there is locked yeah any
lock it oh yeah no oh oh
burner feel right guys just chilling oh
you're gonna ruin his mister so this I
spend about like three hours into the
game
yeah maybe for cuz this game can take
you like 18 if you're playing it long
enough yeah I think maybe average award
in 15 I think there's something on
behind that pallet on the ground behind
where the pallet - you're right I could
be wrong but I'm pretty sure there what
is a pallet that's enough Oh crash down
and just fine it's working they think
that's what I call it maybe it's not
this room yeah I know that from Shane
yeah yeah from Schindler Shinji SHhhh
all right it's not weird it's kind of
cool you have a triggered margarita
[Music]
spits
what spritz what about what's happening
made you say that
I don't know that's that's like the
onomatopoeia for the my bud the spring
of the liquid that turns into fire
flames spread that's right fire you
spray liquid that becomes a flame and it
just makes a spritz noise spritz yeah if
there was a speech
burn it all down yeah go down there get
a little oh you didn't finish it okay
say hi to Lucas Lucas we've made our
reticle red so no just for the know you
need to know you can go through here
yeah I did the guy just sewing your
mother oh really
like through this entire game just to do
that guy in fear the sight I can't pick
it up either
I want some answers
I know you're right and I always wanted
to tell you but I just I can only
remember a little and the rest is just
gone borrow mommy for a little bit
don't just stand there do something do
something
oh come on you think if you drop weight
you could make yeah well no it's not
gonna be enough to empty office lot you
only get four only four you make like
ops handgun water oh yeah now I'll make
you're gonna need more burner fuel I'd
make burner fuel not smart okay sweet
pepper burn there it's there worth
explaining what that's probably I think
so yeah
as an insult what is he preface it with
is like mr. hotshot mr. rubber burner
think you're so cool I was in the Viet
goddamn Nam war that's oh yes very
relevant thank you
attractive specimen she is does I have
plays out the other way install you can
see her early when you first enter this
building if you go straight right
I think I don't know
oh no do we have a micro USB in here
look like seating assistance please help
Richard here to save the day
to see use it doing a great job
don't don't yeah
good to go that's not done yet Oh oh
thank you for that hope will attract
your attention just encroach do this
right now
this guy's is a dangerous one Oh
it's already dead but is it though
alright let's see she picked up that
that puzzle people are feeling at that
that's fine it's great
oh crap anymore what you looking for I
was gonna see if I can make more fuel
already used it up well hopefully she
isn't in this hallway and I could just
make my way downtown oh great huh huh if
this will be good enough
it was for me oh crap looks like
kombucha the bottle are you pouring on
yourself okay you're so cool I'm not up
kombucha we're just not cool
it's disgusting fermented tea yeah gross
probiotics a little bit of alcohol in it
to you yeah as a by-product point it's
like one percenters
party they had to put like warning
labels on it okay like and like change
like one of them got big we're traveling
now thanks Richard
kombucha Kobe sounds like change the
recipe because they won't burn telling
people whatever children getting drunk
big kombucha is at it again
no no oh my god do you have the burner I
ran out of him oh Jesus
dang I was just being a lot of too
generous I think we're fine right yeah
wait if you start the puzzle does it
pause everything no you have yeah we
need a PC mod of this with the Benny
Hill music that plays this body's like
what the wacky sax
Yakkity Yakkity sax
he's totally us you don't know that
probably know if I heard it yeah you've
heard it cuz you could you mime it Jay
did you do it no I think man I can't do
it but I'd be I'm at Scott ah yeah after
Miami the melody it's just a the only
saxophone song I think that plays that
when things are going really fast like
people like running around like crazy
okay okay okay another do you think I
should say this one more fuel that would
save it it's the group decision okay
exactly I got this like super wonder I
hope you standing around some hello just
extra handgun seeing in velocities need
to unload a couple of shotgun chills
yes base in the general direction of her
face no don't do that yeah okay that's
smart
I think you could do it yeah yeah do it
out boss can I make that that is baby
love of the first time you do this in
the the older house in the first house
he's like I made this with the Eagle
yeah yeah game on acknowledging that yes
this is what gentleman yesterday just
randomly you guys she got Hawkeye well
Farrell was like you need to explain a
lot more before this conversation give
me some sort of context that's on 2nd
Street so was there a follow-up to the
hawk yeah it was it made way more sense
as it went on he there was like a hawk
on the sidewalk probably injured and
people were looking at it and circling
around I thought he just glimpsed one in
the sky I thought one likes or lunch or
something my carne asada burrito you can
see that carne asada oh Jesus Tom I was
watching a youtuber yesterday who says
that still you love youtubers so no like
a rainbow succeed dude
come here look bug put up quite a fight
cool interesting little thing that we
can really talk about during a chat so
the VHS tapes give you kind of contact
for the future or past so you did the
Mia tape earlier up in the rec room or
wherever and that at the end of it you
see that crank on the lawnmower so you
know that's there in the present it
gives you pretty cool information about
the future events or past based on when
you're playing you can use that use them
to your advantage
yeah when advantageous yeah when they
talk okay this guy
down the bridge without used on the
bridge with eagle the the stairs that
wait yeah yeah the shortcuts it's just
backtrack yeah that's go through there
no wait no I'm not oh being dumb no
anything no one stairs to do there oh
I'm never gonna go back to go back to
that where I got the burner what the
second part the burner oh oh yeah do the
other drawbridge right
sorry let's jump Joey I know all right
[Music]
really hope she's not around man there's
one just go around yeah she's up
someone's edge dumb note don't she
crossed out don't maybe pistol trick
them do a great job myself here he's
contributing nothing to helping Maddie
is laughing I know this game not up and
I can't speak I only got through the
first couple hours of this game is very
very spooky for me Buki it's impossible
to take one of these out with just a bit
of water
this might be fun holy plane is for a
limited amount of time so I'm pretty
sure you can you can I don't know but I
don't think that works well that's on
the hive it will I guess so will it work
yeah I don't think you you just gotta
use like ten ten shows I'm fairly
certain you half the briefly it'll like
lock me into an animation with like when
I used the
and then it won't hurt me I'll be
totally will hurt you and that will not
work
oh my god I mean shoot yeah you just do
something
Oh check for that maybe that's got
burner fuel but first try the shotgun
because it's funny watching one more I
really I'm almost positive you have to
burn them that's why you can't just do
this
[Laughter]
crankin right wait hey OH
crank that it's another way I'd planned
for this to go that was up all night
going through this run okay got it
fine for Peter Brown kombucha can you
burn it okay oh oh no get Rob Lee thank
you crank help we need help
plenty more burner fuel oh yeah but I
don't have a good fuel stuff let's try
to clear some space here yeah it's do it
might as well make a hell yeah yeah make
some bullets okay no actually no maybe
the motor fuel
oh right things go well we got all the
things we need to get further
Marguerite's to love she's still alive
but that's that's great one thing at a
time okay
oh yeah there's stuff over here
I'm gonna laugh my face off of this is
burner fuel I'll catch your face and put
it back on oh you can use it on the
drawer right here oh wait we're all yeah
and so I do all right
baisemeaux still flies them out totally
oh but I think they're all gone yeah
yeah I don't know something somebody to
me
that's also good nice now what I wanted
though all right got the key we're gonna
want to go over here to make you clean I
going out for her not going that way get
her to lure over this man my grades
wait check that door
[ __ ] [ __ ] Wow but she just see that
oh really that yeah I thought you just
said that unsolicited what think no I'm
not listening it alright it seems it's
Keith oh wait yeah you got it I'll do
good yeah shoot her face
you got nice shoes on my life we came
here with on Tennessee his his
girlfriend John spares
[Laughter]
like I'll just stop mid-sentence ooh
smooches like you was smooching with our
brothers holy [ __ ]
damn pig out Oh mo would they give you
like mr. cheeks bony bombed we love you
Tim Tim Curry yeah we stop climbing try
to get out please die oh I thought she
was dead her face is very Joker is right
now though I think you got her a couple
more shots okay one more
yeah no what you did no I kiss her no
you get out of here
she just becomes black ooze yeah the
inside we're all just black ooze oh wait
I get reloaded life is one big immersion
spoken about you that's true I don't
know what it's like with you what do you
mean it's what you're seeing like Swiss
Army man and you said that heard sirens
like in most need an emergency look life
is one big immersion so this is the
serum you're trying to get cos Zoey said
that there is something that will cure
the disease thing that's making people
hold and you have to eat that D Series
you have to smooch it I don't remember
what like the process was to making the
serum cuz I know you collect like the
arm and like there's body part it's some
kind of weird machine you've got the arm
from the Attic soon as you sit alright
you look blender I can borrow
what about the serum I haven't found any
but I did find out we need to make one a
d-series head and an arm this can't be
right you do go back and Lucas has that
leader oh yeah no yeah he takes it she
says she's nobody's your ally we're here
alright check it out
meet me at the trailer if you find it
now that you have all I guess so
normally I would recommend you go back
to a house quick to get the grenade
launcher with a crow key but I guess you
don't listen experts pretty good though
geez yeah wait actually I don't even
know if we can trigger that part to get
the owner oh you need the way to eat
first so you can burn those wicker
figures in the VHS tapes can you do that
in the main game look if you when you
burn it in the happy birthday tape it
becomes something of a lockpick we don't
have any burn of fuel all right I don't
even know if you could buy so this is
really really good the game's really
good about creating kind of hinting at
what you need to do in creating dread so
you you're like where's the last time I
saw a lantern and no Margaret yeah yeah
and you will see sure back let's let's
show a little bit of her boss fight and
then call it a scream sounds good
the next thing we do I think yeah okay I
look down here right here
Oh No I like that craft Punk has been
here is this the first time you see your
like mutation yeah this is first time to
see a lot ever once a while they remind
you it's a resident game with some
cheesy line like that yeah where they
say you want what the [ __ ] that's
special yeah I feel another shortcut all
the view things lines are kind of kind
of cheesy yeah
should come back to the box yeah yeah
get her cells prepped you could have
probably reached through the grate and
undid that from the other side well you
couldn't oh wait hold on go back but you
don't remem there's something under
trailer it's a chem fluid I think right
under the trailer
oh right under the trail yeah yeah chunk
shotgun shells right place wrong item
right okay get ready
daddy more oh yeah you can reload your
burner yeah just to make more space so
what is that like that bottle on top is
there like cleaning liquids I duct-taped
to the rig or someone did or like some
sort of bleach for the burner yeah if
you're looking it's like a plastic maybe
a gardening bottle supplies knowing that
it was over near the old house you know
you can make those bombs if you take the
works toilet cleaner put it in a like a
2-liter bottle fill it up like a quarter
of the way crumpled up like 10 or 15
pieces of tin foil and two balls put
them in there close it shake it up and
put it down after like five minutes
they'll explode tell me something I
don't already know
yeah I thought we should be discussing
explosive I don't know even make that
stuff anymore
that works the FBI is gonna rappel into
this room it doesn't actually explode it
it's like pops really loudly like a
cannon so unknown fluid
treasure NASA thing for the trailer
there's the toilet now yeah so it'll be
in the trailer now you say there's just
magma bullets though yeah yeah so it
used to be Brooks I wouldn't need that
right now I wouldn't get that tired you
don't either
[Music]
wait where'd you get those steroids an
antique coin thing yeah yeah yeah did
you get a stabilizer earlier I got the
eyes earlier oh my bad so earlier when I
trashed eyes you I was not correct I
thought those are steroids not a
stabilizer it's okay Mike I forgive you
you could use the steroids once you get
red although it might it'll take a
little more time than Darwin angling
yeah myself I'm at risk
use it now you know yeah long game I
would say save it but we're just gonna
stick in this exactly not a few minutes
it's good help increased all right let's
see I thought your name was Ethan Ethan
that is I
nice one thank you
it's actually where was that oh Jesus
sorry God just a good shortcut to have
yeah exactly that's what I was trying to
do see look it's like spray bottles I'm
sorry you thought once I was trying to
get back far enough so she wouldn't
actually graduate you can do that cuz
that's yeah you can avoid being grabbed
keep your distance I just let her
we want to commit to this boss fight
right now we've got like five minutes we
can give you the chance all right I'll
see if you like I believe in go either
die or kill her soon yeah shoot that
like STD of a stomach she has yet there
a lot of supplies on here the first time
I play it actually pops a
psychostimulant here so I could see them
on the run
this is too much yeah that is the one
point together that's the reason I hear
her how are you actually we're
sweetheart
are you in the box burn it all nice yeah
get off the wall
yeah heal up yeah yeah boot in your life
give her a little shotgun splash I like
to say how can you set her on fire and
then shotgun that were Bernhard she can
get a few hits in on you before she
stumbled from the burner yeah I wouldn't
recommend it
no I want to keep it round cuz she lays
the eggs right Brian Krause chief to
watch oh yeah these guys are the real
boss nice you settle down that lump
checked out
actually it's a good idea to
this is all just her attempt to avoid
going getting everything surgically
removed for like thousands of dollars so
we just shoot it all in pain you know
you actually have a cat at night DC -
shotgun shells they're fighting
something your cat in there sex I think
that uh no no you can't do a stab if you
just collapse mine oh my god
and then just shock on her yeah thing
her beach yeah tumble yeah keep going
what great way down the stream well she
just starts disintegrating but no
pressure
oh I feel like you meant to apply some
pressure and I'm not sure why you said
no pressure
he almost you got it he can get past
these bugs it no get to help careful
there's no good
there are spiders on that one vine you
better bug don't sleep that bottle man
oh my god
yeah go find her she's gonna keep
bugging you
that's my drop down here hello
just soundtrack it's kind of off-putting
do you think he's opposed to this song
yeah thanks I know what you're asking
this is penny Hill song comes on see I
can make that joke now if you I get it
oh boy oh that could have come from
anything right there
I think the burner is yet the better
option I know yeah yeah just like I was
trying to put it like sugar sure enough
but yeah I think that's it that's the
animation know you're all looking I hope
so
she's receptive yeah
good clothes no box who cares what's in
the bowl out of help okay
good thing you got her a puppy dog yep I
knew when Kramer's trying enjoyed
imagines the yeah
like about this fight a lot of hunger
the bugs I don't like that part is share
know what they got there you go how did
I screw her up you use the combine
screen
wait there's a combine screen yeah yeah
that's all you got is that the good hair
good nope but this'll do
you got to okay actually you know what
hold altitude and press triangle you got
to enhance the bullets that should do it
see you liked your joke I wasn't I don't
know come on just do it okay so you
don't have to shoot her in that thing
that just does way more damage yeah
Oh God LT was so evil seven thank you
everybody who joined us today again
tomorrow we're going live at 10 a.m.
Pacific to talk about our top three
games so then come back and watch that
it's been a long stream certainly has
yeah and then of course go catch up on
all of our stuff if you have time
tonight maybe you play like what remains
to be the Finch or finish up horizon or
finish up res evil 7 if you haven't
finished it's a fantastic game got
number 4 on our list a bunch of people
thought that representing GameSpot's
collective opinion I agree and we'll be
back tomorrow see you then